yo doing go get marry me frappe okay  let's go alright so this is our mermaid  crab apparently it's really hard to make  the drizzle is all gone already  I appreciate it cease it okay okay  that's good I like it I mean I don't  I taste vanilla and green tea taste a  hint of green tea there's a little bit  of berry almost tastes like melted  vanilla ice cream and like a very  smoothie had a baby and the baby had  like a fling with some Naja  that's quite a description that you did  there it's like a mixture of vanilla I'm  like berries and like there's a picture  seeds right there does yes we tried the  newborn together is this better than  equal friend yes I did even come fast  for me yeah I like the berries trips  into thinking that it might be healthy  because  Oh daddy get off finding a piece  [Music]